hommes des femmes des enfants innocents
vont mourir ou font craindre pour leur
vie nous condamnons cette attaque
barbare et les arguments cynique sens il
a justifié le président poutine a
rapporté la guerre en europe
en ces heures sombres l'union européenne
et ses citoyens sont aux côtés de
l'ukraine et de son peuple
nous sommes confrontés à un acte
d'agression sans précédent perpétrée par
le lit d'un chez bruce contre un pays
souverain et indépendant
la cible de la russie n'est pas juste le
donne pas la cible de la russie les pas
juste l'ukraine cette cible c'est la
stabilité en europe et l'ordre
international fondé sur les règles pour
ceux ci nous tiendrons le président
poutine responsable plus tard dans la
journée nous allons soumettre aux
leaders européens un paquet de sanctions
massives et ciblées en vue de leur
approbation
ce paquet permettra de cibler les
secteurs stratégiques de l'économie
russe en bloquant leur accès aux
technologies clés ainsi qu'au marché
ainsi nous affaiblirons la base
économique de la russie et sa capacité à
se moderniser en outre nous allons geler
les avoirs russes dans l'union
européenne est arrêté l'accès d'une
banque russe aux marchés financiers
européens
à l'instar du premier paquet de
sanctions nous restons aligné sur nos
partenaires nos alliés il états unis le
royaume uni le canada mais également le
japon et l'australie
ces sanctions ont été conçus pour
frapper durement les intérêts du kremlin
et sa capacité à financer la guerre
nous savons par ailleurs que des
millions de russes ne souhaite pas cette
guerre
le président poutine souhaite remonter
le temps jusqu'à l'époque de l'empiré
russe mais ce faisant il compromet
l'avenir des russes l'avenir du peuple
russe j'en appelle à la russie de mettre
un terme immédiatement à la violence et
de retirer ses troupes du territoire de
l'ukraine nous ne laisserons pas le
président poutine
zappé larchitecture de la sécurité qui a
donné à l'europe la paix et la stabilité
dont a joué depuis des décennies nous ne
permettrons pas au président poutine de
remplacer l'état de droit par la force
et la brutalité
il ne devrait pas et ne devra pas
sous-estimer
notre force
et notre résolution sur celle de nos
démocraties liste euros l'histoire l'a
prouvé les sociétés les alliances repose
sur la confiance la liberté et c'est ce
qui fait leur succès et leur résilience
et il sait ce que craignent les
autocrates l'union européenne et aux
côtés de l'ukraine et de son peuple nous
continuerons de l'aider le cren vaincra
nous connaissons les heures les plus
sombres depuis la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
une super puissance nucléaire
attaquer un pays voisin et menaces de
représailles
tout autre état qui souhaiteraient venir
au secours du pays attaqué et ce en
violation du droit international
et en violation des principes de la
coexistence humaine avec à la clé
des milliers de vies perdues et des
conséquences que nous ignorer
l'union européenne va réagir de la
manière la plus ferme possible
le président du conseil européen le
président michel a convoqué une session
de conseil européen ce soir
pour donner les orientations politiques
nécessaires à l'adoption du paquet de
sanctions le plus massif le plus dur que
nous ayons jamais mise en oeuvre en tant
que représentant de la politique
étrangère de la politique de sécurité de
l'union européenne je resterai en
contact avec tous nos partenaires
pour garantir que la communauté
internationale
ce bien saisi de la gravité du moment
et qu'ensemble nous invitions nous
demandions à la russie de mettre un
terme à son action elle car elle sera
menacée d'un isolement sans précédent
une question de blocs début une question
de
querelle diplomatique et l'eau va
maintenant de la vie et de la morgue il
en va de l'avenir de notre communauté
globale
et nous restons unis avec nos
partenaires transatlantiques et toutes
les nations européennes pour défendre sa
position
et nous resterons une
aucune violence aucune destruction le
permettra d'obtenir un gain politique et
l'union européenne reste à l'alliance
les deux nations la plus importante de
parlement ne l'a sous-estimant pense
nous sommes d'ores et déjà en train de
pourvoir à une assistance d'urgence
pour le cren nous permettront également
d'appuyer les opérations d'évacuation y
compris avec notre propre personnel
l'union européenne aux côtés de ses
partenaires transatlantiques
et autres a fait un effort considérable
pour permettre de trouver une solution à
la crise de sécurité
déclenchée par la russie est la russie
est restée sourde
et a choisi unilatéralement
la voie de l' escalade qui menait à la
guerre
le président poutine s doit y mettre un
terme doit mettre un terme à cette
agression insensé et nous pensons nous
penser pardon vont vers le peuple de
craignant et nous resterons à ses côtés
et vous venez
entendre la
présidente de la commission européenne
ainsi que josep borrell le chef de la
diplomatie européenne mme gauthier